so when I look at Celebrities Dennis
Rodman would not make a good spy
it'd be really really hard to put that
guy in Disguise between the piercings
and the tattoos but then you have folks
like Tom Hanks Tom Hanks is like your
perfect spy not only is the guy a great
actor but he is incredibly forgettable
he's just a forgettable white guy even
as I say Tom Hanks people might have a
picture of one character in their brain
probably the guy from Forrest Gump if
Daniel Craig walked into a room would
you notice him right away yes you would
notice him right away you'd either be
jealous of his good looks or you'd be
excited by his good looks that guy's not
going to be a good spy you'll be
familiar with something called the halo
effect or pretty privilege basically the
good looking people seem to have better
outcomes as they go through life but not
if you want to be a covert in fields
intelligence officer yeah if you were to
actually walk through the hallways of
CIA you would be severely disappointed
by the lack of Attractive people there's
a power to ugly